- Those little green boots are cute.
- Aren't they exciting?
They're a little-
- Oh my God. How high up do they
You are cute.
- [Margaret] Well, they go up to here.
- I love your tattoos as well.
- Oh, thank you.
You could see Abraham Lincoln's forehead
and George Washington's forehead.
- I love
What was the idea?
- 'Cause it costs $6 to spread 'em.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
Oh my God.
- I can never raise the price.
- Oh my God.
You win for best tattoo ever.
Oh my God.
That was amazing.
(Margaret laughs)
Okay. So there's no segue
but for summer, do you do anything?
Did y'all ever do family
vacations growing up?
- Well, I would go to
Hawaii with my family
for, you know, just for summer and stuff.
And so,
but the thing is I travel so much
for my work that now I
really love to stay home.
- [Kelly] Staycation.
- Staycation.
I have
a garden of carnivorous plants.
So plants that eat bugs.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So I just watch 'em.
(Kelly laughs)
It's so fun.
- That is so messed up.
- I love it.
And then, you just have like
such a busy life,
so it's great to just be home
and do nothing.
And then I have a bathtub
now in my backyard.
- [Kelly] Yes. What?
- [Margaret] It's kind of
like an above-ground pool.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- See, there's like hot glue.
I was putting up some things.
I know it's so Bridgerton.
- It's so good.
- I'm living.
I'm like, yeah, I fill
it up with the hose.
- Yes.
- No, it's really nice.
And then I put like a
movie screen outside,
so I have a couch so I can watch movies,
and so I watch scary movies.
- Wait, what?
At night?
- At night
And it's all kind of woods behind me
and it's so scary.
And it's so fun.
(audience laughs)
- You have a very weird
idea of what fun is to me.
- Isn't that fun though?
- [Kelly] No.
- You don't like scary movies?
- Nope. I don't like to be scared.
- Oh see, I love scary movies
because I'm always
thinking the worst thing
is gonna happen to me.
So when I watch scary movies, I can relax.
- [Kelly] You're prepared.
You're prepared.
- Yeah, because I'm a
catastrophic thinker.
I like to think, "Oh, the
worst is gonna happen."
So it's almost like I
pre-feel the emotions.
- Wait, I do that with certain things,
especially when I was pregnant.
I literally, this sounds messed up,
but I would go through like
the worst-case scenario.
'Cause when I walked in there, I was like,
"I just wanna be prepared
if that is said to me" like what I need to
I don't want it to be the first time
that I'm thinking about it.
- Rehearsing.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Like you're rehearsing the feelings
so that it won't be such a shock.
- Yes.
But I also think you
might be setting yourself
up for a Dateline Special
by going outside at nighttime
by the woods
naked in a bathtub,
watching a scary movie.
- I mean, but it's all my house.
And I have dogs and really mean cats.
- Oh you have dogs.
See, and they'll alert you.
That's true. Okay.
- [Margaret] So, you
know, it's kind of like-
- Have your Bridgerton moment.
- I have my animals.
I have my carnivorous plants.
I mean, I have, you know,
- My carnivorous plants. (laughing)
- That seems like defense enough.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I like it.
Yeah, I like it.
- Yeah.
- So you're newly single.
So I know what that's like.
So do you like having the
place all to yourself?
'Cause I enjoy it.
- Yes, I love it so much.
I love it
so much.
- Like your room.
You're like, "This is my bed."
- I sleep smack in the middle.
- Yeah? I don't do that.
- I sleep in the middle,
and then I have all my animals around me.
And it's great.
All you need is a really crazy
high-tech security system
and then you're fine.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- I feel like that's
all you need to be safe.
- The dogs too.
- And dogs.
But you think that you feel
you need another person
to keep you safe
but actually, no.
They're actually the dangerous one.
(Kelly laughs)
It's coming from inside the house.
(audience applauds)
- It's coming from inside.
- You know?
- Yeah.
- But isn't it great?
Don't you feel so good?
- You are so funny.
No, I do.
And I used to be terrified by myself,
but now I think 'cause I have two littles
in my house with me,
then I'm the mama bear.
So I don't get like that.
I have dogs and a
security system, and yeah.
- But you have to be there
and not be afraid for them.
- Yeah.
You have to act like you're
Like the power went out the other day
and my kid freaked out,
and I was trying to make it all fun.
Like da, da, da, and still he's like
my kid, he got so scarred, y'all.
He walks around my house,
and he turns off the lights everywhere,
which I'm like, "That's good."
Like energy efficient.
- Yeah.
- But he's terrified.
He's like, "We can't use the lights up,
'cause they might all go out"
and he was like terrified.
So, yeah.
- [Margaret] Oh.
- I know. That's actually really sad.
I don't know why I said that.
(audience laughs)
But you like to get out sometimes though
'cause I heard that Harrison Ford,
did he spill wine all over you once?
- Well, yeah.
I was at a party.
- [Kelly] It's a good story.
- This is years ago
at Carrie Fisher's house.
Carrie Fisher and Penny
Marshall used to do
a joint birthday party every year.
So I went and Harrison Ford was there.
Everybody there was a celebrity.
And it was so weird.
- I've never been to that party.
- It was such a strange,
it was like being in Madame Tussauds
because they were all famous.
And I was just like walking in
and then Harrison Ford was walking through
with like three glasses of red wine
in little plastic cups, like
and I mean, he should
be able to carry them
'cause he's Indiana Jones and Han Solo,
so he should be able to
carry three glasses of wine.
- What a let down.
- But he walked up and he goes, "Whoa."
And he fell
and threw all of the
wine on me, like all on.
But it was him.
(audience laughs)
- You were like, "Fine."
- I was like, "It's fine."
I mean, I was kind of really excited.
I was really starstruck.
(Kelly laughs)
I was really excited.
- Was he so embarrassed?
- He was so embarrassed.
And he was like, he grabbed a napkin
but it was on my front
and he was like, "Oh, oh, oh."
(Kelly laughs)
- Can't pat it down.
- Didn't know what to do.
And it was just the most adorable thing.
It was really, really sweet.
- I love that you're like,
"Han Solo and Indiana Jones.
What an epic fail."
- He could've just whipped
off the stain maybe.
But I don't know.
He's just very,
it was one of my favorite
celebrity moments.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- That was exciting.
- Yeah. That's cool.
Well, speaking of parties
your new movie is called "Fire Island."
- [Margaret] Yes.
- Which is known for
summer parties, right?
- Well, it's a
beautiful place.
It's a very gay summer romantic location.
And the movie is written
by Joel Kim Booster.
He stars in it.
He's an incredible, incredible comedian,
incredible writer, incredible actor
and Bowen Yang stars in it,
and Matt Rogers, who's
a huge fan of yours.
- [Kelly] Oh.
I like him already.
- And we talked about you
a lot actually on the set.
And we had a great time talking
about you, and he had
actually come with Joel
to this show
and stayed backstage
and cried in the dressing room
'cause he loves you so much.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- But he was so nervous.
Didn't wanna rock the boat.
- What? I'm like the most friendly person.
- I know.
I wish he could be here, but he loves you.
- [Kelly] Oh. Well next time.
- Yes.
- Okay. We need a quick break.
You can see Margaret in
"The Flight Attendant",
which I'm so excited about on HBO Max.
And watch out for "Fire Island"
premiering tomorrow on Hulu.